hello and welcome to logistic regression
in our my name is Peter Ferrari and I am
with the simply learned team and today
we're going to cover logistic regression
in the our programming language logistic
regression is kind of a misnomer in that
when most people think of regression
they think of linear regression which is
a machine learning algorithm for
continuous variables however logistic
regression is a classification algorithm
not a continuous variable prediction
algorithm but just a regression is also
sometimes called logit regression in
this video we are going to learn why we
would use regression as a predictive
algorithm what is a regression the
different types of regression is I've
already mentioned some regression
algorithms are classification algorithms
and some are continuous variable
algorithms why use logistic regression
what is logistic regression and then
we'll look at a use case a College
Admission using logistic regression so
why would we use regression well let's
say we had a website and our revenue was
based on the traffic that we could drive
to that website whether through R&D or
marketing and we wanted to predict the
revenue based on site traffic and the
website traffic would be related to the
revenue we could generate the more
traffic driven to our website than the
higher our revenue or at least that's
what we would intuitively assume and so
we need to predict the revenue based on
our website traffic here we have the
plot of revenue versus website traffic
traffic would be considered the
independent variable and revenue would
be the dependent variable often the
independent variable or variables if we
had more than one could be called the
explanatory variables and the dependent
variable would be called the response
variable however we typically refer to
them as independent and dependent
variables so our intuition tells us that
the independent variable drives the
dependent variable and if there is some
relationship between the two variables
and we would say that there is a
correlation between the two variables
and then we
be able to use the independent variable
to make predictions about the dependent
variable if you look at the chart on the
right you'll see there is a clear trend
between website traffic and revenue as
website traffic increases the revenue
increases and we could draw a line to
show that relationship and then we could
use that line as a predictor line so for
example what will revenue be if our
traffic is 4.5 K and we see that when
the traffic is around 4,500 the revenue
is around 13,000 and if we could draw a
perpendicular line from 4.5 km the axis
and the x axis the traffic axis up to
the orange regression line some kind
called the line of best fit then we
could draw another line over to the y
axis the revenue axis and we could see
where it lands and that would be the
prediction so in this example when the
traffic is around 45,000 hits the
predicted revenue is around 13,000
normally we wouldn't actually draw those
lines we would generate an equation and
we would call that equation a model and
we could plug the independent variable
into the equation to generate the
dependent variable output which we would
call our prediction so what is
regression regression is a statistical
relationship between two or more
variables where a change in the
independent variable is associated with
a change in the dependent variable it's
important to note that at all variables
are related to each other for example a
person's favorite color may not be
related to revenue from a website here
the change in one variable height is
closely associated with the change in
the other variable age this makes
intuitive sense as you get older from
when you're born you get taller and it
seems to make sense if we plot that data
we would see those green points on the
graph up to some certain age where
growth would taper off and the plot in
the middle of the screen we see the
clear linear relationship between age
and height which is indicated by the
solid red line we sometimes call that
line a trend line or a regression line
or the line of best fit and we see that
the height is the dependent variable and
age is the independent variable
of course you might ask doesn't height
depend on other factors of course it
does but here we're looking at the
relationship between two variables one
independent and one dependent age and
height there are various types of
regression linear regression logistic
regression multiple linear regression
polynomial regression and there are
others decision tree regression random
forest regression linear regression is
probably the most well known and by
definition when there is a linear
relationship between a dependent
variable which is continuous in an
independent variable which has
continuous or discrete we would use
linear regression when the Y value in
the graph is categorical such as yes or
no to or false they voted they did not
vote they purchased something they did
not purchase something it depends on the
X variable logistic regression is when
the Y value in the graph is categorical
in nature for example yes/no purchased
don't purchase voted did not vote and it
depends on the X variable notice the
trend line for linear regression and the
line for logistic regression they're
different more on that later
and there's polynomial regression as
well when the relation between the
dependent variable Y and the independent
variable X is in the nth degree of x
sometimes we say an nth degree
polynomial of X in this picture you can
see that the relationship is not linear
there's a curve to that best fit
trendline so why would we use logistic
regression and we need to understand why
we would use logistic regression and
that linear regression picking the
machine learning algorithm for your
problem is no small task and it really
behooves us to understand the difference
between these machine learning
algorithms linear regression answers the
question how much so in our earlier
example if website traffic grows then
how much would revenue grow whereas
logistic regression would answer what
will happen or not happen linear
regression in general is used to predict
a continuous variable like height and
weight
regression is used when a response
variable only has two outcomes yes or no
- or faults often we refer to logistic
regression as a binary classifier since
there are only two outcomes so let's try
to understand this with an example let's
say we have a startup company and we are
trying to figure out whether the startup
will be profitable or not that's binary
with two possible outcomes profitable or
not profitable and let's use initial
funding to be the independent variable
here we have a graph that shows funding
versus profit and it appears linear once
again our intuition tells us the more
funding a start-up has the more
profitable it will be but of course data
science doesn't depend on intuition it
depends on data but this graph does not
tell whether the startup will be
profitable yes or no it only states that
with an increase in funding the profit
also increases that's not binary if we
wanted to predict how much profit the
linear regression would be useful but
that's not what we are being asked hence
we need to make use of logistic
regression which is two outcomes in our
case profitable and not profitable so
let's draw a graph again the x-axis will
be our independent variable funding and
the y-axis will no longer be the
dependent variable profit but it will be
the probability of profit for example if
you look at a company with a funding of
say 40 then the probability that that
company will be profitable is around 0.8
or 80% based on the best fit line called
a sigmoid curve in the example we
plotted several companies some with 10
15 20 some with 50 60 or 70 or 65 and we
indicated whether they were zero not
profitable or a one profitable on the
graph and this is how we should think of
logistic regression in this example
given the amount of funding we calculate
the probability that a company will be
profitable or not profitable and if we
use the threshold line of 50% then we
have our classifier if the probability
is 50% or higher the company is
profitable if the probability is lower
than 50% it's not profitable so what is
logistic regression this is a linear
regression graph
so let's compare linear regression to
logistic regression and take a look at
the trendline that describes the model
it's a straight line which is why we
call it linear regression but using
linear regression we can't really divide
the output into two distinct categories
yes or no to divide our results into two
categories we would have to clip the
line between 0 & 1
if you recall probabilities can only be
between 0 & 1 and if we're going to use
probability on the y-axis then we can't
have anything that is below 0 or above 1
thus we would have to clip the line and
once we clip the line we see that the
resulting curve cannot be represented in
a linear equation so for logistic
regression we will make use of a sigmoid
function and the sigmoid curve is the
line of best fit notice that it's not
linear but it does satisfy our
requirement of using a single line that
does not need to be clipped for linear
regression we would use an equation of a
straight line y equals B sub 0 plus P
sub 1 times X X being the independent
variable Y being the dependent variable
but as we've said we cannot use a linear
equation for binary predictions so we
need to use the sigmoid function which
is represented by the equation P equals
1 divided by the quantity 1 plus e to
the minus y he being the base of the
natural logs then taking the log of both
sides and solving we get our sigmoid
function and graphing it we get our
logistic regression line of best fit the
applications for logistic regression are
endless here we might have a couple of
gardeners or farmers and one farmer says
I am planning to grow plants in my
backyard and I want to know whether my
trees will get infested with bugs which
I'm sure is a huge problem in these days
the fewer pesticides we use the better
off we are for health reasons
the young lady says I can use logistic
regression in a model to predict it for
you and the other farmer says well how
is logistic regression going to help but
we know that healthy versus not healthy
is a binary classification and we can
use a binary classifier like logistic
regression to solve this problem which
is what the young lady has in mind
if we have the data we can model the
data and generate a sigmoid function
that best fits our data and then use the
probability of a healthy tree versus a
not healthy tree or an infested tree
once again we see our sigmoid line of
best fit and some points that represent
healthy trees and not healthy trees once
again we plot our sigmoid curve scratch
that and once again
once our sigmoid curve is plotted and
our threshold is set almost always at
50% we can use the sigmoid curve and
calculate the probabilities and here the
independent variable of width which I
assume is an application of pesticides
or no pesticides to determine whether or
not the probability of healthy is
greater than 50% the threshold or less
than 50% the threshold and now let's
take a use case of a college admission
problem of course we can't solve
anything using data science if we don't
know what the problem is so we need a
problem statement and here the problem
statement is simple we are given a data
set and we need to predict whether a
candidate will get admission in a
desired College or not based on their
GPA and college rank so the very first
thing we need to do is import the data
set and if it's a small enough data set
and it can fit into our computer memory
then we are golden otherwise we have
some work to do the data set that we
were given is in CSV format
comma separated values CSV files are
easily imported into our environment
once we import the data we next need to
select and import the libraries that we
will need although our is a great
programming language with a lot of
built-in functions it is easily and
powerfully extended by the use of
libraries and packages then we need to
split the data set into a training set
and a test set it's important to note
that the data set that we've imported
that we were given as the GPAs and
college ranks for several students but
it also has a column that indicates
whether those students were admitted or
not so what we're saying is that the
data set has the answers and if you
think about it it must how could we
possibly train a model have a
learn if we didn't know the answers
already that's why it's called machine
learning so we train the model and then
we test them out once we split the data
into training and test sets we will
apply our regression on the two
independent variables GPA and rank
generate the model and then run the test
set through the model once that is
complete we will validate the model to
see how well it performed so now it's
demo time
so here we have our studio my favorite
IDE or integrated development
environment and I have a script already
composed to run our logistic regression
on the problem at hand which is our
college admissions problem so let's just
walk down the script before I run it and
talk about the various points in the
script so first define the problem while
the problem was defined and you really
can't do anything in data science
without a clear problem definition once
the problem is defined you can load your
libraries acquire your data set the
working directory in my case I'm on
Windows Explorer the data munge the data
if necessary and then prepare the data
scale the data if necessary split the
data into train and test data sets and
train the model using the training data
and run the test data through the model
and then validate the model for accuracy
and precision etc so here we are going
to load our libraries I'm going to use a
package called CA tools and now that the
library is loaded I'm going to set my
working directory and if I come over
here to the files tab you'll see that
there is my working directory in that
working directory there's a file called
binary dot CSV and that's the CSV the
comma separated value file that the
College gave me I'm going to ingest and
then look at that data and as you can
see it has four columns GRE GPA rank and
then the answer column it met whether or
not someone was admitted which would be
a one or not admitted which would be a
zero and if we come over to the right
and we can look and see some of the
first few values of each of those four
columns now let's split the data we're
going to take this my data frame and
split it into two a training set and a
and the ratio we're going to use is 8020
so 80% of the data will go into the
training set and 20% will go into the
test set now that ratio could be 6040 it
could be 70/30 typically it really
depends on the size of your data how
much data you have but this is for our
example and for our purposes 80/20 is
perfect next we'll do a little data
munging in general you munge the data
early on after ingestion and you really
have to be careful in this case we don't
have any missing values we don't have
any real outliers our data was pretty
clean when we got it and ingested it but
in general that's not the case and a lot
of work and a lot of attention needs to
be paid to the munging process here
we're just going to take our data the
admission column and the rank column and
convert them to categorical variables
right now they're integers as you can
see on the right-hand side and once I
run these two lines they will be
converted to factors and all the fun
stuff we're going to use the GLM
function the general linear model
function to train our logistic
regression model and the dependent
variable is it met and the independent
variables are GPA and rank and a little
tilde sign here says the dependent
variable will be a function of GPA and
rank the two independent variables the
data will be the training set and the
family will be binomial and binomial
indicates that it's a binary classifier
it's a logistic regression problem there
it is we ran our model and there's a
summary of our model you can see that
there is some statistical significance
in GPA and in rank by the coefficients
and output of the model so next let's
run the test data through the model
and once we have done all that we can
now set up a confusion matrix and look
at our predictions versus the actual
values again this is important we had
the answers and now we took and we
predicted some answers so hopefully our
predicted answers match up with the
actual answers I'll run a confusion
matrix as you can see the predicted
values versus the actual values and it's
important here to know that if it was
predicted false and it was actually
false and we see 189 or if it was
predicted true and it was actually true
which is 27 we did well on those but
there are a few that were predicted
incorrectly some were predicted Trueba
were actually false some were predicted
false that were actually true and now
we'll confirm when our percentage
accuracy is 72 percent not bad but we
could probably do better how we'll leave
that to another video
what for now let's talk about our key
takeaways so what are the key takeaways
we've learned why we use regression what
regression is and some of the various
types of regression we also learn why we
would use logistic regression it is a
binary classifier and it's very good at
that in general are there other binary
classifiers sure well gistic regression
is easy to understand and easy to
implement and sometimes it's the first
choice what the logistic regression is
as opposed to linear regression and
other types and then we used our College
Admission problem as a use case and use
logistic regression to answer our
questions thank you for joining us and I
hope you have enjoyed this training
session feel free to post your questions
in the video for more information please
visit
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here